this guy here is a porcupine okay all
right who doesn't and people call him
prickly pigs and if you look at her
sweatshirt right there look at your
sweatshirt
what kind of internship is that
you can grab a there's a banana worst
internship
whoa he's okay can I feed this guy right
here hold it up like this maybe he'll
sit up okay but one misconception of
these porcupines everybody thinks that
they can shoot quills I don't think
people think that you don't think so did
anyone here think that a porcupine can
shoot a quill out of its body no nobody
thought well okay
misconception is that they breathe fire
and can fly into space
you're just saying any crap that comes
into your head
let me believe they have life insurance
run on huge snakes what's special about
this snake this one um very nondescript
this is a full-grown snake It's called
an African egg eating snake now check
out those eggs that I just put out there
on the other the other side oh these
these check out how the tiny head on
this animal it can actually open its
mouth so wide that it can swallow eggs
that size really amazing this snake does
not have teeth because eggs Don't Run
Away look it's kind of looks like it's
kind of interested should I put one out
and see if it does anything it probably
won't but it probably won't but you
never know look it's thinking about it
it's thinking about it it's thinking
about it it's read the studies on
cholesterol
so what they do is they they open their
mouths their jaws on hinge they swallow
that giant we have a picture here I
believe can you put up that picture of
this and so it's opening its mouth that
wide and they swallow the egg whole and
then they have vertebra inside that have
points on them that stick down and they
jab into that shell and crack it and
then they suck out all of the insides
and then what they do is they they
basically they throw up they throw this
up into this bowl right here that's
Insanity they they throw up that yeah
and they suck the egg out of the shell
they've sucked the egg out of the shell
but they don't want to digest the shell
because who wants to digest items you
don't want to go to a restaurant with
this snake no it's not a disgusting
process of opening its face exactly
extracting the nutrients and then
vomiting up pretty much and I would say
you probably don't want to bring any
snake into a restaurant so untrue that's
a generalization if there was a Nobel
Prize for weird sex this animal would
have it in what way what are they into
these books their sex takes 13 hours it
starts with something we're using
doesn't sound long to me
come to think of it yeah we can we can
do the calculations later but they are
said to have the most complicated sex
you can see what you think it starts
with the male chasing the female pretty
typical move male face female mammals
then they wrestle they actually wrestle
for a couple hours and they uh basically
push each up each other up in the air
there's like all this juggling going on
and then the male has to calm down the
female and he puts her feet in his mouth
and she trembles with excitement and
then he climbs up on top and presses her
down and masturbates for about three
hours
[Applause]
problem
this is a monitor lizard you want to
hold this guy as well ah you tell me do
I do I want to hold this guy this guy
definitely is dangerous he's got big
teeth and they have a really bad bite
this tail would whip you but you can see
he's pretty calm pretty relaxed let's
check him out like that you want to hold
him so what you want to do stand up
you put this hand like that okay and I'm
gonna grab them oh God this and you put
your hand underneath his chest like I
got like the other hand for his tail
okay so you can see those claws
this hand let me put foreign
[Applause]
[Laughter]
that we know
it's shockingly lifelike
this one is the very very coolly named
screaming hairy armadillo look at that
so
it's a creaming hairy armadillo yeah
hold them just like that hold them on
the sides yeah you're not good at
telling what to hold do we go ahead
right here on the side okay okay and you
can just hold her just like that this is
actually a female wait a minute wait
okay I'm curious you're here
good job
you're saying you're saying that this is
a female that is a female that's the
tail yes a little appendage sticking out
there
it is the tail is indeed the tail but I
will tell you what that would have
fooled me if I had a few drinks in a bar
armadillos armadillo males have the
largest penis relative to their body
size of any other mammal so it dwarfs
maybe that's all I gotta say
it came in a close second
path tickle her tummy just give her a
little wiggle she's not gonna bite okay
she really likes it you can see her
little her little feet starting to go
okay and this just she likes this yeah I
think so yeah
and what's happening here she does seem
it does seem to be calming her a little
bit Yeah you see her she's clearly
excited
I also like her tummy because it's it's
orange and it matches your hair
sweet and creepy thing to say
this is the budgets frog the what's from
budgets frog it's from Paraguay and uh
it is actually one of the most vicious
frogs I'm not sure if it's going to get
vicious on us wait but point it that way
towards the camera right there so that
America can enjoy what you say this is a
vicious frog yeah I'm not sure if he's
gonna like
if you can see inside he has fangs this
is a Fang frog down below sounds like
the devil
fangs
any
hour is a really exciting frog what
there's no point in this way he's like
they're actually uh called the Freddy
Krueger frog because they sound like a
cat being tortured I'm told
okay
who told you that oh yeah oh my Lord now
these guys are really look how they
carry the tortoise in
it looks like it looks like he beats
he's been drinking all night he just
this is an African sulcata tortoise and
this is a domestic goat these guys
actually live together and goats as we
all know like to hop on the back let's
see if he'll stay up does that ever
happen they ever do that yeah this is
what this is what the goats do when
they're
so you're saying
that left to his own devices the goat
will get on top of exactly goats love to
be up high it's sort of a dominance
thing and the goats that live with this
tortoise use him to get up top and say
I'm King of the Hill and there he goes
he's just yeah he's trying to he's
trying to join the band right now
I'll tell you what the thing that's
really hey he's like I play the flute uh
the thing that's really ironic about
this pairing is that why domestic goats
that have been released into the wild
have actually caused giant tortoises in
some parts of the world to go extinct
because they eat all the food so don't
tell him that because it will ruin his
friendship with this guy but you know
big problems
well look at him now he's bummed out
he's stunned
he's over by the planter thinking it's
all over now they're really awesome oh
my God I know what this is this is this
one is a toucan most people know what
toucans are
from you know the famous cartoon I'm
gonna pass you these so this is a toucan
a tropical bird from South America
these are for him and
I got confused you hand when you someone
hands you a bowl of blueberries you tend
to just use she's ready to eat so so go
like this and three times
to
three whoa
you want to hold her sure do you mind
yeah let's see you're trying to see if
she'll do it there you go now hold your
hand up like that
beautiful beautiful
I am the least intimidating of The
Avengers
also I'll mentioned throw a grape yeah
toucan man from a great my way and it'll
be defended
okay that's just you're just kidding
it's kidding thanks for the blueberry
juice yeah you're pal you're probably
gonna have to get that suit dry cleaned
in fact it's not mine anyway heartbeat
the local weatherman whenever we have
animals on her poop is dark blue because
of all the berries that she eats so yeah
you're a little obsessed with their poop
I've noticed she didn't go to the
bathroom on you you know when you work
with Wildlife you know you pretty much
get pooped on almost daily so it seems
to be your thing he really likes to have
his armpit scratch and if I can get my
hands you say these things that end up
not being true
they love it when you rub its belly he
really likes to be sealed in a pumpkin
yeah all right they love it when their
Airway is restricted
oh there we go okay right here yeah you
got it you got yeah that seems like that
see how he's calming down yeah
the eyes of a very calm animal
see how calm it is
[Applause]